question do billionaires create jobs the
answer is no entrepreneurs create jobs
I'm an entrepreneur and I do my best to
create jobs but the reality is in order
to become a billionaire the one thing
you have to have is luck any billionaire
who tells you they could just do it
again no you have to be lucky maybe you
have a rich parent question I get asked
a lot is should billionaires pay more in
taxes yeah we should pay more in taxes I
would not be in this position without
this country nothing happens that's
great whether it's Health Care teachers
roads you name it without people paying
their taxes it may be painful when you
write that big check but just think
about how you got there one of the most
patriotic things that you can do when
you're wealthy is pay your mothering
taxes